وصل احمدتي الى ولايه نهر النيل زياره
خاصه الى منزل البرهان استقبال بحفاوه
ونقاش حميمي حول مستقبل السودان
هذه الصور كانت قبل نحو عام حليفه الامس
صراع عدوين فلا شيء ثابت بالسياسه
[موسيقى]
قبل نحو 20 عاما كان اللقاء الاول بين
قطبي الصراع في السودان التقى حميدي
والبرهان في دارفور قاتلا في خندق واحد
بعد 12 عاما تشاؤل اقدار ان يتقاطع طريقا
الرجلين مجددا
ويتفقا على ارسال قوات مشتركه من الدعم
السريع والجيش للمشاركه مع قوات التحالف
في اليمن كل
رجل واحد
تعززت العلاقه بين احمد والبرهان لتصل في
العام 2019 الى دعم الحراك الشعبي للاطاحه
بحكم البشير
في وحدتنا كلنا قلنا الكلام ده قلنا قوتنا
في وحدتنا وما زلنا بنقول الكلام ده في كل
يوم احنا قوتنا في وحدتنا نحن وحدتنا
وتماسكنا هي وتماسك السودان
واليوم ينفرط عقد التحالف بين حميتي
والبرهان فالسودان كاي سفينه لا يمكن ان
يقودها قبطان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات